[Musique]
c'est dans l'hémicycle du palais de la
source jeudi 10 décembre que s'est
déroulée la remise des prix de la
deuxième édition du concours
départemental du film scolaire signer
collège mon établissement conçu écrit et
réalisé une vidéo autour du thème et
l'identité réunionnaise que je ne t'ai
une opération que département porte à
destination des élèves pour qu'ils
rencontrent un peu les métiers du cinéma
c'est à dire qu'on le donne la
possibilité de s'exprimer sur ce qui les
préoccupe aujourd'hui en tant que
collégiens et on leur donne aussi par la
même occasion de rencontrer des
professionnels du cinéma pour pouvoir
mettre en image leur vie de tous les
jours et de pouvoir les anime et on va
en tout cas au toit d'une aventure
humaine tout simplement
après délibération du jury c'est le
collège de la marine qui a remporté le
premier prix du concours 2020 avec son
film chez mémé
[Musique]
dieu on a fait beaucoup d'efforts c'est
difficile à certains moments mais on
s'est beaucoup amusé
les principales le prix du public
revient quant à lui au collège chemin
morin dans le film space créole a
largement été appréciée par les
internautes
[Musique]
ils ne connaissent pas du coup on se
rend compte d'evans comblant des outils
et
on devient amie en fait je leur apprends
le second prix du jury a été attribué au
collège de montgaillard suivi par le
collège chemin morin les collèges en
albanie et terre sainte remporté
respectivement le 4ème et 5ème prix
[Musique]